yeah and the specific eye mask we use is
a phenomenal I think it's called sleep
master put a link to it in the show
notes Sean it's it's a great eye mask
and you both sleep with earplugs in I oh
man
yes see like that's like for me when I
have our clients they're like man I'm
not sleeping good I don't ever even ask
him that like I don't do it and I should
I should do your terror I'm the worst
pre-med person at like I watched the Oh
have like the news and like fall asleep
to the news so like I can't raise my
hand to complain because I'm not doing
what I should be doing huh to do it
right yeah so we don't have a TV in the
bedroom intentionally we try to avoid
the blue light at night
Beck's has the the blue blocker glasses
the the sleep mask the earplugs those
work well blackout curtains are are
really important for us oh yeah we have
a white noise machine as well and that
you know it creates that ambient sort of
noise that well I hope so you guys this
for both of your blood works I remember
I could say both they're mad I don't
remember specifically for you Joshua but
I remember and I'm looking at Rebecca's
right now is both of your insulin-like
growth factor ones are higher than
average which is usually a sign of
getting quality deep sleep now we may be
tired but you may be that just might be
you but there's some obviously things to
do to try to improve that but I know
that's good improved with the
testosterone the the igf-1 improved with
with testosterone but we'll see people
that it's in the 80s right and and
that's it's gonna carry on throughout
your body you're gonna have the worst
skin hair those kind of things you're in
it's an indicator every time that they
sleep that so I think based on hearing
what you guys are doing you're probably
doing a lot of right things are just
sometimes we still have a mind right and
our mind is man it can do what it wants
to and we have to controlling that you
know whether it's meditation or just
that that's that's the other challenge
to is physically changing our
environment but really changing
internally that's the that's the tough
part that we all have to be accountable
for right that's actually where
come back to recently is like done a lot
of stuff we've played around with
hormones and whatnot and I'd still like
at the place where I really would like
to sleep deeper more deeply more
peacefully perhaps and it's become
pretty obvious that what I really need
to focus on is meditating the internal
stuff right meditation I'm gonna be
doing some daily slow yoga right things
that are chill basically cuz I'm not
very good at chill right you know yeah
so so back side I think that's a good
point
bringing meditation back in to the top
of mind being being more focused on it
is something that can be done it also
might be that you know you just have
trouble with deep sleep and and it might
it might be that this damn ring that's
on our finger here that's a sleep
tracker I was talking to Kris Kelly
about this kind of introduce you to
Chris Kelly he's great dude he runs a
nourish balanced thrive which is a great
company who does similar things to you
but with like gut health testing and
which is also super important very
important especially with all stuff I've
had going on but I it may be it may just
be that tracking your sleep
for me it's helpful it might be
detrimental for you and I've come like
I've flirted with that line several
times over the last well how long we've
had these four four years
something like that yeah I even did that
with my I got apples eye watches or
whatever in it and I'd see it I'm like
why didn't get that much sleep I was
upright like I was like arguing with a
do you think you are I know when I was
awake or not alright no beer doesn't
your wife Rob but I need you fall asleep
nope I'm like you were snoring